i have no say in it gibbs it's a
pirate's life for me
savvy we've got a tale for you one that
involves pirates the caribbean
and a whole lot of danger movies like
pirates of the caribbean are full of
high action stunts and fight scenes that
look lethal
well the filming of some of these scenes
were dangerous and led to plenty of
on-set cast injuries and
even ended the career of some stunt
doubles other times the most unexpected
scenes are the ones that landed actors
like johnny depp in the hospital in this
video we'll be showing you what pirates
of the caribbean scenes were treacherous
to film
the pirates of the caribbean production
found themselves tangled up in legal
trouble when one scene went wrong while
filming dead man's chest
remember this epic captain jack scene
[Music]
well this was the last scene johnny
depp's stunt double tony angelotti
filmed before his career ended
he was tasked with being dropped from a
crane where he would perform the rope
unraveling we see in the final cut
but it didn't go as planned and he ended
up in intensive care
i had the five wraps around my waist i
spun
so uncontrollably fast that the
centrifugal force actually ripped my
pelvis apart
ouch the worst part is they couldn't get
it perfected at half height but
still moved on to the 80 foot drop in
the same film orlando bloom's stunt
double zack hudson
said that this mill wheel fight was one
of the most dangerous and difficult
stunts he filmed for pirates
many days doing crazy fights going up
and down the wheel fight i had not
rehearsed or had time to prep for it
i had to do all the wire work involved
on top of the wheel and the whole fight
scene
to top it all off jack davenport said it
was a hundred degrees while filming the
scenes and that he was continuously
fainting the entire time
he called the whole experience intense
a moving wheel swords and a hundred
degree weather
seems like a potential recipe for
disaster
johnny depp even had some struggles with
the mill wheel ones that left him
unable to walk properly for quite some
time he may not have had any trouble
walking on the mill wheel but he had to
get strapped onto the contraption
it was just exhausting i just it was
days and days and days of that
not only were the straps too tight but
he was in that position for so long that
it caused nerve damage in his feet
i lost feeling in the upper half of my
left foot for about four or five months
like the professional he is he
persevered and continued filming
we all remember the iconic ending to
curse the black pearl where jack sparrow
ends up behind the wheel of the black
pearl
well that sequence was filmed in
entirely one take which according to
stunt person tony
made things very complicated that took
months of rehearsal
it was a ratchet of me flying out of the
water probably like
35 to 40 feet in the air and then
another ratchet pulling me into the boat
and a de-accelerator landing me onto the
deck of the ship
they managed to get the shot without
injury but tony admitted that things
could have gone wrong in that setup
pirates of the caribbean isn't the type
of movie where they use fake weapons
they were wielding full-on metal weapons
as you can imagine things got quite
intense two types of swords principally
the shorts and
what are called small swords jack
davenport called those scenes
learning an exhausting and slightly
dangerous dance
to make sure things went as smoothly as
possible all the actors had to undergo
training with knives
swords and explosives what could go
wrong
there was one very specific sword fight
during the blacksmith's forge scene that
resulted in an injury and a
very angry johnny depp orlando bloom and
tony angelotti had been filming the
scene and said
the fights they'll get really intense
and fast orlando i think got lost at one
point and went to another direction
and i ducked back and the tip of his
blade caught right near my eyebrow
johnny was supposedly extremely angry
and
made sure they got the medical team to
check tony before continuing
we can watch jack sparrow steal the
interceptor on repeat
however the scene actually turned pretty
dangerous for johnny and even resulted
in an accident
in the dvd commentary they revealed that
while filming the ropes on the ship
didn't break at first which caused
debris to crash into johnny's knee
if you pay attention to the actual scene
you can see it happens
however it just looks like johnny duck's
johnny got lucky with this one and
didn't end up with any serious injuries
but it's still frightening to realize
how things can go wrong in just a split
second
ironically while filming the cast and
crew got into a real-life boating
accident
kira knightley who was on the night
shoot with her mom was the one who
experienced it firsthand
to make it even worse keira knightley
was still a minor at the time
just 17. their ship hit a reef in the
middle of the ocean
thankfully they were able to return
safely to land but from then on they
switched
all the ship scenes to in studio johnny
depp has been praised multiple times for
how involved he gets in production
it's interesting to be yeah put up
against an obstacle like that you know
it's a nice challenge well in on
stranger tides he may have gotten a
little
too involved he overworked himself with
his stunts so much that it resulted in
injury
i ended up with this bad sciatic
situation it was this horrible grinding
electricity going through me
just like with his previous injury he
powered through the rest of the film
pirates always warn about getting into a
fight with a kraken
and we think we found out why stuntman
zach hudson said during this scene
he had to make a 400-foot drop and
it's a moment he'll remember for the
rest of his life he broke down just what
he had to do for the scene
i'm on top of the sail mast about 150
feet up in the air as it's breaking
i jump with a single safety wire into
the sail across the way
it ended up being about a 300 400 foot
drop
and jump across at least he had a safety
belt
orlando bloom remembers filming the ball
cage scene in dead man's chest as one of
the
wildest experiences just one look at the
behind the scenes footage and
you can see why the bone cage sequence
was
it was crazy orlando did the stunt
himself and the height they were dropped
from was
definitely cause for concern the end
result was
pretty epic though stunt people have
admitted that high altitude jumps are
usually some of the most dangerous
stunts
but for this specific waterfall jump the
height wasn't all they had to worry
about
christopher leps johnny's stunned person
on this film said he had to navigate the
jump so he didn't hit
any rocks you can actually see peeking
over the top of the water in the final
cut
it was about a 45 foot jump and i had to
clear like
15 feet of rocks to be fair they tried
to be as safe as possible
they'd been filming in hawaii at the
time and just couldn't find any water
that wasn't rocky
cayes got lario's experience on
salazar's revenge was a dream come true
except for the part where she ended up
in a sling for a couple of weeks
the weather made filming on black pearl
very dangerous and kaia took a tumble on
deck dislocating her shoulder
she was so worried about holding up
production she said i went to the
hospital quickly had some morphine and
was back on set
that's called dedication sometimes on
set
it's the crew that are putting
themselves at risk destroying the
endeavor wasn't just done with vfx
the crew actually destroyed a built ship
in studio with pyrotechnics
while they're controlled and handled by
professionals there are still risks
the camera operators were protected
under fire resistant blankets and wore
ear plugs just in case
other times it's not humans at all that
are at risk
filming on pirates of the caribbean
actually got quite dangerous for the
animals and wildlife that were nearby
their explosives used in the water were
used at the cost of diminishing the
ocean life
there were reports of sea life washing
up on shore for weeks after filming
the production even received strongly
worded calls to take accountability from
organizations like peta
it wouldn't be an over-exaggeration to
say that hollywood puts their cast and
crew at risk
almost every week who knew a little rain
on deck could lead to a dislocated
shoulder while hearing about the dangers
is scary
thanks to safety protocols they've
managed to keep
set life pretty safe what scene do you
think wins for being the most dangerous
to film